i've been researching podcasts and
podcast creation uh this research
actually began uh right before the
olympics
hard to believe that that was also this
year
so i was looking at a sports podcast and
experimenting with the dolby io apis
now these apis include some media
processing tools that can be pretty
interesting data points um which of
course you know got my data science
brain doing loops on like all the
possibilities for some of the
applications
um and so i got pretty into the audio
data space i explored a lot of projects
relating to podcasts such as
like ad insertion like natural ad
insertion and podcasts which
uh if we get some time we'll chat about
that later um and i'm hoping to few
share a few of my like takeaways my
gotches
and learnings from this research with
everybody here
uh but before we get on to that like
what exactly is audio data and why
should you be interested in it
well sound as we perceive it is
fundamentally just a series of
vibrations pass through a medium and
interpreted by an ear
you can hear me now because the speakers
in your device compress air in such a
way that you can interpret it
of course i'm not speaking in front of
you in person so between the step of
projecting and interpreting these air
vibrations is the computer where audio
is stored as a you know a series of ones
and zeros
and when converting these air vibrations
to the zeros ones the computer needs to
sample the air pressure at a repeated
rate known as the sample rate which is
often 44.1 kilohertz or 44 100 samples
per second
additionally the samples are taken at a
resolution known as bit depth or rather
the number of bits stored per sample
which is commonly 16-bit
hence to store one second of audio
at 44.1 kilohertz and 16-bit storage
requires 44 100 times 16 times one
second bits or if converted about 86
kilobytes
additionally most audio is two channels
uh which doubles this figure and some
mediums record audio at much higher
sample rates and bit depths
okay though who cares right well for
comparison uh a character which is the
amount of storage uh required to store
just like one character is only uh eight
bits
and that means to store my entire script
for this presentation only requires
about two kilobytes
so why is audio so much more storage
intensive
it's because the recording is capturing
uh much much more than just the
instrument or the voice speaking into
the microphone
and the mistake lots of beginners make
when analyzing let's say podcasts you're
doing a podcast project
is assuming that getting like a
transcription or rather just the word
spoken in that audio is like enough of
the picture
and that's not to say transcriptions
aren't useful as we'll see later
transcriptions are like a great addition
to your data set
but lots of tools or guides you find on
the internet just convert the audio to
text perform the sentiment analysis on
the text rather than the audio signals
and continue on that way
but obviously like something is lost in
this conversion and so much data is
wasted
and this is the exciting part about
audio data it's such an incredibly rich
data source with so much information
captured that we're really only just
beginning to utilize it in data science
for what it's worth
and i like to describe audio data as
like sneaky big data because a lot of
people you know they they
don't see it taking up as much space as
it actually does or being as information
dense so i like to joke that like sneaks
up on you a little bit
um now of course your next question is
uh where can i find this data
if you go check out dolby io slash
awesome audio we actually have a curated
list of awesome audio technology
resources for developers including a
list of data sets
that you can use and the locations of
where you can find audio samples
we also include stuff like social forums
and networks for collaboration and
contribution
educational resources
and some useful code samples
now everybody is welcome on this
collection so if you know any cool audio
resources and want to make a
contribution
please do absolutely please share
great
so now we know what this audio data is
and where you can find it so how do we
use it more specifically how do we use
it effectively
well i'm going to outline three tools
and run through a notebook to show you
so you can get a good look at how they
work
and more specifically i'm going to look
at these tools on a collection of
podcasts which as i mentioned earlier
has been part of my research with the
company
now why did i choose podcasts well
podcasts provide an interesting mix of
music and intros and outros
it has a lot of speech and the speech is
sometimes split amongst multiple
speakers at irregular intervals
not to mention podcasts have like
exploded in popularity over the last few
years
with apps like clubhouse routinely being
you know the top of the app store
um now this podcast series we're going
to explore consists of 20 episodes each
varying in length in addition to getting
the episodes we also collected some
supplementary data um such as like how
many how many downloads each podcast got
as well as the dates that they were
released
so i'm going to switch over to a
notebook
now
um and please by the way i mentioned
this if you guys have any questions or
anything like that drop them in the chat
i'll be pausing a few times throughout
this to answer questions and we'll also
hopefully have some time
at the end
additionally
this
notebook is actually available
i've got all the notebook stuff there i
couldn't provide the audio samples
explicitly
however
[Music]
here is the notebooks available if
anybody wants to take a look at those
i'd recommend probably not following
along for this presentation just because
it takes a second to find the audio
samples and alert and a few minutes to
install some dependencies but if you're
interested in tinkering around with it
after the presentation the github link
is right there
um so great so i'm going to start in my
uh analysis or uh
analysis notebook so
we're gonna begin with uh every data
scientist's favorite part of starting a
project which is getting all the
dependencies and imports to work
uh now i'm hoping everybody here
probably recognizes a few of these tools
in the basic
imports things like matplotlib for
plotting pandas numpy
uh in matplotlib i like using 538 style
for presentations i think it comes out a
bit clearer
we also include some
nltk dependencies if you haven't worked
with the natural language toolkit before
please don't be intimidated by all these
imports we'll kind of get on and have a
chance to talk about them later
as well as some stuff from pi audio
analysis which is another package that
we're going to be looking at
but to begin i kind of just want to look
at like this basic data that we
collected in conjunction to the audio
samples
so the first thing i want to explore is
we have
20 episodes in this podcast series how
many downloads are each episode getting
and can we see any trends
and the first visualization i have here
is just exactly that the downloads per
episode
and we can see that like episode 1
started out pretty strong
then kind of dropped down a little bit
before having a sudden and rapid spike
in popularity for episode 12.
and then after episode 12 it drops back
down again but it drops back down at a
bit of a higher level than uh that began
and already like this kind of raises an
interesting question like what was so
successful about episode 12
um you know and and why was there such a
spike here why did the viewership drop
you know after episode one was it not to
the expectations of the viewers
it's already some interesting questions
um and we can also look at the minutes
per episode because maybe episode 12 is
just like a two minute snippet you know
um but it's actually not uh it's
actually the longest episode in the
series so something they did in this
episode turned out really right
and that's interesting to think about
we can also see that episode one was the
shortest and from there they've kind of
been getting progressively longer
duration
with some spikes
which is pretty interesting
so that's kind of like our basic data
again if anybody has any questions
please drop them in the chat
but this is kind of like you're scraping
your data this is the basic stuff you
get
and let's get a little bit more advanced
here so as i mentioned before uh
just looking at transcriptions misses a
lot of the picture but uh transcriptions
and natural language processing are
great to supplement the data set
so we're gonna have a look at the
transcriptions now
transcriptions are really good if you
guys don't know what transcriptions are
it's pretty much converting these spoken
words in a podcast to text
now transcriptions are really great for
stuff like content analysis what are
they talking about in these podcasts uh
sentiment analysis you know are they
speaking favorably or disfavorably about
certain topics uh and classification
tasks like can we start grouping
podcasts based on certain things that
they're saying you know
now i've included a transcription
notebook
um for me i got my transcriptions using
azure cognitive speech to text
services speech to text
if you don't mind muting i'd really
appreciate that
um yeah as your cognitive services uh
speech to text services which has worked
well for me um to use that transcription
service uh you provide an api key you
store your files on the blob and provide
a pre-signed url and then you provide a
pre-signed url for the output container
now again there's like a ton of
transcription services out there this is
what worked well for me using their rest
api
of course this one does cost though so
if you're looking for a free option
another one i was experimenting with is
pocket sphinx
which is a free alternative
it's not going to be quite as accurate
as speech to text
but it is free
and it does run locally and running
locally uh if you're you know analyzing
some podcasts that are like an hour an
hour and a half long
it can also tie up your computer for a
little while so it's a good thing to
consider but included in the notebook is
just some code in case you want to
generate these transcriptions yourself
cool um so what we're going to do and
actually i'll i'll show the output of
the transcriptions so you can kind of
see
uh what that looks like from azure
cognitive services uh they output into
json
uh and they give you some basic metadata
like you know the duration of the audio
file and stuff like that then they
provide a lexical which is all of these
spoken words in order um as well as
including like a couple of different
models
uh like a display which you know
includes all the plug all the
punctuation
and most interesting i think are most
useful is they also include the
sentences transcribed
at certain kinds of time stamps
which is very useful for keeping track
of like which part in the podcast
they're talking about various things
uh as well as like you know
confidence ranges uh and a few different
models so you
i like i mean i like azure speech to
text it it gives you a few different
options to play with um yeah that's kind
of
kind of the gist of that so what we're
going to do is we're going to start by
loading in these transcriptions we're
only going to worry about the lexical
for the moment just because
we're just beginning with some really
basic transcription analysis
and we're going to count out the total
words in each podcast
so interesting again 20
episodes starting at 50 000 words all
the way up to 90 000 words
here is the word count by episode
and already some of the interesting
stuff to have a look at here is like
episode 19
despite you know being shorter than
episode 12 not much shorter but it is
shorter
does have like a significant amount more
uh spoken words
just interesting to think about you know
maybe they had some people on that
podcast that talked really quickly and
we're able to pack in a lot more words
or maybe the opposite is true for
episode 12.
so it's interesting to look at that but
i think uh
we're probably more interested in the
number of unique words
each podcast presents
and again we see episode 12 kind of
shoots up there it's the longest one it
makes sense that they'd have the most
unique uh
most unique words and it's interesting
though for like episode 19 how there's
that like decrease in word or that
increase in word count but decrease in
unique words are they maybe like
repeating a few points or hammering some
particular topics home that they just do
it again and again
it's interesting stuff to think about um
now let's break out into the first
episode
now what i'm doing here is i'm taking
the first episode and i'm having a look
at the most common words in that first
episode now how this works is with the
word tokenize package in the natural
language toolkit which splits all of the
words out into individual entities
and then we can call frequency
distribution on that which
pretty much just counts everything right
if we plot it out we can have a look at
podcast one and we can have a look at
the uh
most common words that have been used
and how often they've been used
uh and in this case it's pretty standard
it's kind of what you expect it's like a
lot of
joining words or connecting words or
just like stopping words things like i
the like you and they
so this doesn't necessarily tell us a
ton but i think it's interesting that we
pull out some words like think or like
no can tell that maybe perhaps they're
making predictions in this podcast and
there's some interesting stuff there
now if we filter out the common english
stopping words stopping words are kind
of just these words that we talked about
here that maybe don't add much to the
overall context of the podcast
um but are picked up in transcriptions
so we can filter those words out by
using a list of english stopping words
which we downloaded and imported before
and from here
what we can do is we can then
calculate a frequency distribution for
the most common words once we've
filtered out the stalking words
and this is good because we get a bit
better of a picture of the uh
like the content or what they're talking
about in this like first episode of the
podcast again you see some stuff that
isn't super telling like like and not in
r
no
but you do see some other points such as
team
game
three four two five
twenty
and this uh maybe gives you a bit of a
hint as to what kind of sports podcast
we're looking here
looking at here um ones where
scores of things like three are you know
pretty common uh and a team game uh some
interesting stuff here and if you know
you're american sports you probably
already have an idea of
kind of what sports this podcast talks
about but
interesting to see that in a scenario
where we're not listening to this whole
podcast we can actually start to draw
out some of this meaning
uh brayden sorry to interrupt you
there's one requirement from one of the
participants uh he's asking if it's
possible to zoom in the well
to visualize it a little bit bigger
maybe i'm not sure if that's a
the inquiry
yeah thank you for mentioning that does
this does this look a little bit better
uh i think i i think we can appreciate
it well what do you think about it um
tom
can you appreciate it better
yeah if uh
if he if
people just want to throw some messages
in chat i can play around with this a
little bit and get the view a bit better
all right so
el is thinking very much for the
548 designs and the mention of the ads
you know your coding
and someone was also asking about a
common format for the transcribed audio
the only issue is that i do not fully
know which
which format he was specifying
well um maybe i'll jump back and answer
a few of those earlier questions in a
second but it looks like they're happy
with the size of the code for the moment
so that's great thank you for stopping
me on that
but assuming this is all good and it
looks like it is i can keep going so
um one of the really cool things that
you can do with transcriptions is you
can do some basic sentiment analysis
uh now for me i'm just using vader
valence aware dictionary for sentiment
reasoning
which is the lexical approach to
sentiment analysis and what it does is
it pretty much just assigns words
certain positive negative or neutral
scores
like the word bad would get a higher
negative score than the word great
it's a really basic approach to
sentiment analysis i think for the
purpose of the analysis that i'm doing
here this is a a great place to start
however if anybody is interested
in playing around with this again the
notebooks are available please import
some more advanced models and see if you
can learn more about the sentiment
analysis
um
but for the purposes of this it's pretty
simple and i'm just using a pre-trained
uh model provided in the natural
language toolkit so i haven't even
trained it specific to uh podcasts
now um for this episode one right here
we can have a look at the distribution
of sentiment
throughout the first podcast
and this is
pretty interesting at a baseline we can
see that all right like there's a little
bit of negative sentiment majority's
neutral which makes sense if we go back
up to you know our most common words and
we see things like the and like those
words don't really carry a sentiment
with it so it makes sense that we're
getting a pretty high neutral score
um what i think is more interesting is
the fact that on average we're getting a
little bit more positive sentiment than
we are getting negative sentiment
and this of course depends on the model
that we're using in this case we're
using a pretty basic one so it's not
very context aware it's maybe not
picking up on things like sarcasm
but for the moment we'll just assume
that this podcast is kind of more
positive
than
negative
and so this is for podcast one here the
first episode
now let's break it out and let's see if
we can calculate this stuff for
all of the podcasts
to kind of get a bit of a better picture
of like how sentiment changes um across
the uh
notebook so we're calculating out the
sentiment um by each of the podcasts
that we present
and we can see here um
we've got the
negative sentiment in red the positive
sentiment in green and the neutral in
gray and these are each of the episodes
1 through 20 and this is kind of like
the percentage composition if we get
this sentiment across the entire
transcription
and there's a few interesting things
that we're seeing here we can see like
episode five really
really goes hard on the negative
sentiment compared to like a lot of the
other episodes
uh and i think that's really interesting
especially if we scroll back up and have
a look at the downloads per episode we
can actually see episode 5 was not one
of their most popular episodes and in
fact the following episode after that
was really
really unpopular
so perhaps
the popularity of the episode
um or in fact how negative episode five
was might have contributed to how
episode six you know wasn't wasn't that
great or wasn't that that well received
we also see our most popular episode uh
episode 12 kind of has the least amount
of neutral sentiment in it in fact it's
more positive and more negative which
suggests that maybe in this podcast
they're talking about some more
polarizing topics there's maybe a bit
more debate it was maybe a bit more like
emotive and energized which might have
been why it was like a breakout episode
for him why it maybe had some viral
features to it uh because you know it
was taking a different stance on on some
of the things that they're saying
uh which is pretty interesting i think
it's important to calculate the average
out across the whole series and we'll
see why later on you can see that on
on average the series is a little bit
more uh positive than it is negative
um but overwhelmingly neutral and we'll
return back to these values a little bit
later as we kind of do some more
in-depth um
analysis uh but what we can do is we can
also um load in the first podcast again
and specifically we can calculate out
the change in sentiment by sentences so
in the first podcast they have 1200
sentences in it
and if we look at just the
first sentence to the 10th
sentence
we kind of get a bit of a plot that
looks like this
so this is the aggregated sentiment
score or as the sentiment score gets
added over time to contribute to the
overall sentiment um and this is the
breakdown for just the first 10
sentences
and it's interesting to see that in the
first couple you know not predominantly
positive it's definitely a little
negative but over time the positive
sentiment begins to overtake the
negative sentiment present
and this
you know becomes more pronounced as we
scale out the boundaries so if we look
at like 100 sentences for example you
can see this separation really just
starts to grow and now at this point you
know red is not catching up to green and
green's absolutely not catching up to
neutral
and we have 1200 sentences so if we
bump this up to
oops if we bump this up to a thousand
we can see these lines really begin to
straighten out
now there are 1200 sentences
so if we instead specify the range to be
uh let's look at the last
let's look at the last 50 sentences here
of the podcast uh this is another
interesting thing to kind of see
and see that in the last 50 sentences
the
negative
or the aggregated negative sentiment um
tends to flatline uh especially when
compared to the positive sentiment which
grows
and in the context of podcasts this
makes sense right like you want to leave
your viewers on a high note you want to
leave on a positive note thanks for
watching really appreciate you guys
watching our podcast or listening to our
podcast
and again it's just interesting to see
that reflected in the data
now before we jump onto the next tool
let me have a look at a couple of
questions in here if you have any more
questions please feel free to
drop them
in the chat
all right so we are going to follow up
the questions at this moment
one question comes from jim he's asking
about the rough course in time and money
for usher to transcribe an hour long
postcas a podcast yeah
yeah
yeah well that's a great question um so
there's two costs you actually have to
factor in for sure you have to factor in
the blob storage as well if you're
storing this stuff on the cloud
uh if i recall correctly signing up for
an azure account for the first 12 months
you get like 200 worth of credit so
storing it on the cloud if you're not
storing like an insane amount of data um
that should cover out there
but if you want to use cognitive
services
you don't it doesn't cost from the 200
that you get when you sign up for the
account you have to put in extra money
um i think to transcribe about an hour
and a half long podcast just using
speech to text it was about like 20
cents ish
uh but that's also because we're doing
the most expensive kind of transcription
which is the one that does
every
single model that they have so i can
then take and compare them
you could instead pick out the model
that works best
for
the particular language that your audio
is in and the
i don't know if people have accents or
whatever some models work better than
others and that if you focus in on just
using one model that might bring the
cost down um substantially
all right that's another question from
tom
he's asking this could you simply
extract unique identifiers that
correspond to real life objects and
correlate with frequency of mentions on
twitter
then you would know if the episode was
on popular subject
yeah and that's a that's a really good
point if we want to supplement the
performance of the podcast with say like
some social media scraping to see
where and when people are mentioning it
that would be a really great idea and
you'll actually see later on we do some
stuff where we pull out like specific
organization names and specific like
nouns from the
text that we've transcribed and i
imagine it'd be something pretty similar
if you want to do it in terms of
scraping on social media
and i think that's all the questions so
i'm going to proceed
so the next package that we're going to
look at and we'll kind of come back to
these as we go on is
pi audio analysis now pi audio analysis
is an open source package by theodorus
giganopolis
who is a researcher principal researcher
multimodal machine learning at the
multimedia analysis group
now this is an open source package i'll
drop it in chat in case anybody wants to
take a look
but it includes some really quite cool
and useful stuff that you can do
uh on the actual signals in the audio
data so we started by generating these
transcripts well now let's go a bit
deeper and let's see what we can learn
from the signal specifically
and they do stuff like feature
extraction classification and regression
segmentation
uh some data visualization stuff which i
really like as well as some other
functions like uh transcoding
um so i really like this package for
stuff like exploratory data analysis eda
because of those visualization packages
it lets you get working on the signals
really quickly without having to think
about you know potentially messing
around with some matplotlib stuff or
anything like that
it's really good at creating features
for data sets based off of the signals
which in turn is really useful for
clustering and classification
applications
now for this i'm going to switch back to
the default style of plotting just
because uh it uh
renders a little bit better if we just
stick to the basic matplotlib um
style guide
and also what i'm do is i'm going to
trim out 20 minute snippets of the audio
rather than do the whole podcast and
this is just because this package does a
lot of calculations and it can be quite
it can take a long time to run
so we're going to trim those out for our
sports podcasts and we're also going to
pull in some business podcasts so we can
do a bit of a compare and contrast
so while that's running i'll go talk a
little bit more about the package
um
now the feature extraction model is
really interesting and we'll get on to
what a few of these mean but what it
pretty much does is it takes the signals
and the audio
and converts them into 34 different
features
based on like windows of time that you
want to look at and if you have two
channel audio this doubles so what it's
doing is it's creating these like 64
length vectors because we do have two
channels of audio in this case creating
these 64 length vectors
of features for things like energy zero
crossing rate which we'll talk about a
little bit more here
now zero crossing rate is the rate at
which a signal changes from positive to
zero to negative and from negative to
zero to positive so you imagine this is
the rate at which a signal flips its
polarity
and energy another term uh that's kind
of worth knowing is the sum of the
squares of signal values normalized by
the respective
frame length
now that's a kind of complex explanation
there but you can pretty much just
imagine it as a measure of signal
strength
now
full disclosure i am not like a signal
engineer a lot of the stuff i've just
kind of learned working with audio data
so uh
you know it is stuff that you can pick
up if you're a first-time user please
don't be intimidated by all this crazy
technology um but also like i might make
a couple of mistakes so please let me
know if you do know about this stuff
but what we're going to do here is we're
going to look at zero crossing rate and
energy for
our first sports podcast trimming so the
20 minute trim of our first sports
podcast
and we're going to use a function
provided in the kit called feature
extraction
now we're going to narrow down to just
one channel of audio for this feature
extraction and we're going to specify a
window and a frame
now the interesting thing about all
these values is you can calculate them
for
any length of audio like we can take an
hour and a half of audio and calculate
a zero crossing rate
problem is is that over long durations
it kind of just like averages out to a
mean doesn't really tell you much about
specific segments
so here we specify a window and we
specify a frame now the window is like
the amount of time that it's looking at
and the frame is like the
calculations that it's making within
those windows so it's going to make two
calculations for each frame the frame
length is of 0.05 seconds so it's a
pretty small frame and we're going to do
that for 20 minutes
and if we do that for 20 minutes takes a
second to run
you can imagine how long it take to run
for the full length of the podcast
and we get
output two graphs here with their data
visualization package
the
zero crossing rate
and the energy
now
on their own these terms are like fairly
abstracted from what we understand like
noise to be
so it's really hard to look at these
graphs
in isolation and go all right like cool
like i can see that this is a sports
podcast you know
but where it does get useful is if we
then run the same function for our first
business podcast is a 20 20 minute trim
of that
and compare and contrast
because again in isolation we can't
really understand as well what we're
looking at
um however if we contrast it then to
like a business podcast we can kind of
see how these values are denoting some
kind of separation in the underlying
signal of the audio
a few things to note here is that uh
this zero crossing rate is on a scale up
to 0.5 and this energy is on a scale up
to 0.3
and now these are the plots for our
business for one of our our first
business podcast
uh and we can already see like well the
energy for example is way lower scale
only goes up to 0.14
whereas up here you can see it's all the
way up to 0.3
there's definitely like a lot of
difference in the spikes of intensity in
signal in the sports podcast
than the spikes of intensity in the
business podcast it's a bit harder to
see this with the zero crossing rate but
again you can see that it's probably on
average just a little bit lower than the
zero crossing rate for
sports podcasts with a few more spikes
up here
now we're going to return back to this
in a second but let's have a look at a
few of the other visualization stuff
so we can generate uh chromograms now
chromogram is a transformation of a
signal's time frequency uh properties
into temporally varying precursors of
pitch
now what that's a fancy way of saying is
is that
we have like all of this cool signal
data
but there's a huge range of like signal
that falls outside of human
comprehension because of our ears
so what we can do is we can plot a
chromogram which kind of takes that
signal and it plots it along a scale
that people might be a little bit more
familiar with uh which is like a music
scale right a all the way up to g g
sharp
uh now chromograms are typically more
useful for things like like music um but
it's kind of interesting to
see that one the package includes this
stuff
and two the differences between this is
the business podcast here uh and this is
the sports podcast here
um and if we actually change the
boundaries of this out a little bit so
that's just three seconds if we
look at it like on a scale of like 100
seconds
you can see some more concrete patterns
form
so again in our
sports podcast we can see high
concentrations of action
at g
at d at b and a
uh whereas for our business podcast it's
definitely like a lot stronger at a and
b
d
f and g you can kind of see these
highlighted segments where the brighter
the individual segment part in there the
more intense uh the audio is for that
part
now this is just some basic
visualization stuff just kind of showing
you with the package
what i find is really useful is the
feature extraction function i'm not
going to run this because it takes a
second but what it does is it creates
vectors
of all of these different features for
each channel
and what that ends up looking like
is we get these really big
we get these really big
csv files and numpy arrays of like
vectors of features that are present in
the audio
and let me just get up an example for
you here
yeah we've got this example
and you can see what this kind of looks
like in a csv it's just these huge huge
vectors of numbers
and again we specified frame length in
this case i specified a bit bigger of a
frame length so it'd run a bit quicker
um
but you can see
all right here are all of our features
up to about 60 for our two channels uh
and then across
all of these different
columns um so again this is like fairly
abstracted for us humans we can't like
look at all these numbers and really
understand what's going on but what it's
really useful for is feature uh
like clustering and visualization so
this package includes another function
which you can run
i'm not going to run it because it takes
a second
but i ran it before
and what it pretty much does is it uses
these big csvs to actually generate
some like clustering and to try and
split our audio samples up into groups
so
and it outputs it in a
really cool visualization in html but
you can see we had 10 business podcasts
and 20 sports podcasts
and what it's done is it's used the
features in these matrices to
one cluster them into separate groups
which is what we get here these are all
of our business podcasts in blue and
these are all of our sports podcasts in
red sports being 1 to 20 and business
being 21 to 30.
um
as well as pulling out some of the
signal based connections between these
visualizers between these uh audio
snippets so you can see here for example
episode one shares some kind of signal
based connection
with episode three
five six and seven
whereas episode 20 really only has one
connection which is to episode 12.
and we see this in the business podcast
as well um
you know 21 connects to like almost all
of the other podcasts that like 22 24
and 25 uh kind of don't find any matches
and this is a limitation of the data set
we only have 10 examples
uh or 30 examples total but 10 examples
where they might share connection
and you can see for these ones here some
of those connections
are found later on
now what these connections are
fundamentally is like we've got all the
signal data we have these huge feature
vectors um
it's just able to pull out like some of
the reoccurring themes between
these audio samples
and if we plot out uh some of these
features individually let's actually
start with the first metric which is
energy
um now if we plot out energy
here again we have our business podcast
and here we have our sports podcast
you can see that like just
in this signal there is like some
separation
between
like business podcasts which have been
mastered a certain way and sports
podcasts which have been mastered a
different way
and this might be because you know of
the microphones that they're recording
on or might be because they have access
to some kind of audio engineer who's
able to
uh you know correct the audio a little
bit better and it's interesting to see
that this plays out so much and we can
have a look at a few different other
metrics this is the zero crossing rate
which we talked about
not as much difference
you can see a little difference
an interesting spike there
we can look at like some of the other
features again we have a whole heap to
play with here
you can kind of see
some differences and begin to understand
like okay this is how like it's able to
cluster these a certain way is that
obviously in these underlying
calculations that it can make on the
signal it's able to find some
differences
and that's why i really like this
package is kind of like a first pass
you're starting on an audio project you
have a bunch of audio samples you don't
really know much about them
this is a really good place to start
because you can just go and find some
more natural clusters and break them out
into some groups and see if you can
actually identify some patterns in the
signal which is pretty interesting
now again i'm going to pause for a
second uh and get some questions to
anybody here all right
braden that's the first question from
tom
so he's asking
it would make sense to line it up with
transcribed text so the energy is on per
sentence basis
you could analyze how specific words are
stressed
perhaps
how do you analyze how specific words
are stressed yeah
yeah absolutely and that's uh that's
actually another great idea so if we go
back up and have a look at our
definition for zero crossing rate for
example we actually see that it's pretty
commonly used in things like speech
recognition and music information
retrieval and this is because this uh
zero crossing rate feature when you do
line it up with certain words does help
like indicate which word that person
might have said um
along with all the other features you
absolutely can line it up yeah
all right there's another question from
from e.l cousin
he says hey nice visual nice
visualization what is the name of this
type of plotting
yeah so i think it is called a core dial
i'm not 100 sure on that but that's what
the package calls it a core dial which
this kind of makes sense when you look
at it it does kind of look like a bit of
a dial but yeah
okay thanks
all right so there are no more questions
by now so i think we can continue on
brayden
great yeah so for our next package uh
we're going to be looking at some dolby
io stuff now dolby io has a bunch of
different media processing apis i won't
focus specifically on analyze and
analyze speech
now these two apis are great for
generating data from
audio files
um specifically for stuff like content
structure and uh
composition speaker diarization
um it also helps with like better
content creation by providing features
related to uh
like uh the quality of the audio and
stuff like that
so if we want to use these apis i have
another notebook over here for for
generating a data set using the apis
you will need an api key
which means you've got to sign up for an
account for our stuff if you want to use
it um but
we specify our api key we specify the
empath for where all this audio is and
then we specify two outpats the reason
we have two outpats is again because
we're using two separate apis we're
using an analyze audio
and we're using an analyze speech api
now the first thing to do when using
these apis is we want to upload these
files to dolby cloud storage
and this like once it's up on the cloud
storage we can then run our apis on it
but you don't have to use dolby cloud
storage specifically you can use any
cloud storage you can use like s3 you
can use azure you can use uh google
so what this code does is it just takes
a whole directory of files and uploads
them
and then you start analyze jobs or you
initialize a bunch of analyze jobs on it
and we do this by specifying the url
that we want to send the request to
media analyze
we specify our header we define a body
with the input of the file um as well as
like what our output's going to look
like it's going to be now put in json
and we send up
these jobs
now
hour and a half long podcast it does
take a few a little while to run
um so what this script here does is it
then just like queries the
the server and when the files are done
it just downloads them
back
now the uh analyze audio results i can
pull it up and show you what these files
kind of look like
um the output is in json format
and we can have a look at some of the
information that's contained so we get
some basic metadata about the audio you
know durations bitrates stuff like that
and then it breaks it out by process
region
uh and generates um
like loudness readings for every like
segment throughout the podcast
uh it also
gets us some interest
interesting information
such as the signal to noise ratio
music
and the percentage of music in the
podcast speech
silence
and in this api it actually breaks the
silence out into particular segments
that are time stamped so you can flag
them in the audio go check these
segments and all right we've got silence
here we you know can remove silence from
this section
silence is an audio defect just as like
the name describes like if you have a
portion of your hour-long podcast that's
like two seconds of just like no signal
reading
even though it might not be the biggest
deal that is like kind of a waste of
space when storing the file
and it can provide a bit of a strange
experience for users you know if you're
just saying to a podcast and there's a
couple seconds of silence in there you
may as well just get rid of it
um and silence isn't like a pause like
when somebody's talking and there's a
pause like a silence is like an
awkwardly
long period of time
where there's just like nothing
happening in the audio
so being able to flag those out is
really useful
and then the other api we use is the
analyze speech and same thing we upload
those files then we start a bunch of
analyze speech jobs uh query for when
those jobs are done and download them
and the output of the analyze speech api
uh is really interesting
again we get our metadata but now it
starts to break out things like the
number of speakers the percentage of of
talking that goes on
and then it takes these speakers and it
breaks out specific points when they're
speaking
so we can see uh like talker one uh
he jumps in at
section one here which starts about six
seconds in and he speaks for two seconds
this is like right at the very beginning
so it's likely you know him just saying
like hi
i'm a guest on this podcast or something
um and it breaks it out for every single
talker in it so you can see these files
are really big
it also includes stuff like a quality
score
and loudness readings
quality stores are really good because
if you have like multiple speakers on
this podcast and maybe using different
microphones or ones like calling in
um
their audio quality might be lower might
be better
and it's interesting to kind of look at
like how that can change and uh if for
like if you're like an audio engineer
maybe you can go and correct it for that
specific speaker
now i see somebody's got a question
um yeah
terrible name
yeah yeah sorry um
uh sorry marcel i'll just ask myself um
so is this
is the
um speaker is that metadata that's given
or is it something that um was inferred
uh the met like all of this data is just
inferred from the audio file i mean
things like the codec that it was
uploaded in mp3 um i don't specifically
know the inner workings of the
engineering um but everything else is
just inferred specifically from the
signal itself
so the fact that it says number of
uh speaker talkers is six that might be
there might be a mistake might be even
eight or it might be actually four but
this is what it inferred in for six
people
yeah exactly it inferred it that it is
six people and what we can sometimes see
especially in the podcast space is if
they play
like a clip of audio for example like
you know five minutes they're talking
about whoa this is a video that i saw
the other day and they play that
the algorithm does pick up the fact that
like there are speakers in that audio
segment that they're playing
um which gets added to the data set even
though those people might not have
literally been in the room where they're
doing the podcast does that make sense
yeah that's pretty cool i'm just
imagining like let's say you have an
impersonator right you have um like a
comedian on then it might identify the
different impersonations of different
people potentially
yeah yeah no abs absolutely uh also if
like yeah people did like accents and
stuff like that or or spoke different
languages it can it can do that stuff
but
yeah that's that's that's our analyze
api um so we get output in a bunch of
these jsons and what we can do is we can
load them in i really like using pandas
for this task
um now when loading in pandas i
recommend using the json normalize
because we have some heavily heavily
structured json data
and i also recommend using a max level
of 7 if you're going for stuff that has
like between like 5 and 20 speakers
which some of our podcasts do have
and we can look at this flattened out
we get a bunch of different data here
some interesting stuff
you know the signal to noise ratio
the noise level
percentage
when we get to those silent segments
that i was talking about in the analyze
audio before
flattening that out into a data frame is
uh hard and it wastes like a lot of data
because you're just repeating a ton of
stuff over again so i actually keep that
just stored in there
in its
normal form
and the first thing i want to do
actually with these files is i want to
break out
and have a look at the composition of
each podcast to see if we can learn a
little bit more about the podcast
so again we have our 20 sports episodes
and this is the composition
speech in blue this makes sense it's a
podcast it's gonna have a ton of speech
music in red they likely have intro
music and outro music so that's getting
picked up and then silence and again
silence is an audio defect and
especially if you look at it in the
composition of the overall podcast you
can see some stuff like a lot of these
examples like that might be up to five
percent silence or like five percent of
your total hour and a half long podcast
it's just silence segments like
that's not great um now also the uh
composition is greater than 100 in some
cases because music and speech does
overlap
um and you can think about in the
context of their playing their intro
music and then as the intro music's
fading out they're jumping in and saying
hey welcome to our podcast
um
so that's kind of interesting with the
analyze audio with the analyze speech we
do the same thing we can load it in
again
we actually have a few less columns this
time because this picks up a bunch of
extra
extra data just about the audio in
general this is more focused on the
speech
um and again we can see when it breaks
it out by particular talkers
you get uh we keep it stored in that
that json format
so we can get our columns we can kind of
get the shape 20 podcasts
15 columns
cool
now i'm actually going to draw for this
segment here uh and i'm drawing with a
mouse so
apologies if this if this looks terrible
but it's easier to explain if i draw it
now in the case analyze speech we have
this like heavily structured json where
we have all right this is podcast number
one
and in podcast number one we have
speaker number one and we have like
speaker number two
uh and speaker number three
and now speaker number one well he's
talking he speaks in like segment number
one and speaker two
they also speak in a segment and speaker
three also speaks in a segment
uh segment one and then he also speaks
in segment two get the idea there's a
lot of like different layers
to like how this data is structured
so it already poses a challenge for
visualizing this data
and there's a lot of different ways you
can think about how you might want to
visualize data like this
one of the ways that i came up with is
representing these podcasts actually as
a matrices
so
instead of
keeping it in the structured json format
i represented matrices where this is
speaker one this is speaker two this is
speaker three this is speaker four
now let's say for example that our audio
snippet that we've analyzed is only like
ten seconds long so one two three four
five six seven
so forth right
so another way of representing this
rather than in the structured form is
like an is speaking notion right and the
idea is that all right if speaker one is
talking in second one we're gonna set
that value is equal to one and if he's
talking second two we're gonna set that
equal to one as well in second three
but maybe he stops talking in second
four well we set that to zero
now two isn't talking so zero zero zero
and then they start talking
so you get the idea what we're pretty
much doing here is we're building like a
matrices of is speaking ones and zeros
so we can track like who is speaking
when
and that's what this code here does what
it does is it
pretty much populates this vector called
empty here and i call it empty because
people are more often not speaking than
they are speaking
um
and we can use that that matrices to
then plot stuff
now what you're probably seeing here is
already well that's a three and that's a
two those aren't ones
and so what i've done here is i've
actually overlaid all 20 podcasts into
the same matrices so that we can get a
look at the whole series of like how
intense conversation is in certain
segments right
for example in the like opening
like 10 seconds there's probably gonna
be a lot of times when speakers one two
and three are talking let's have a look
at like the the probability of this
um we fit this all into the same vector
by setting the uh number of columns to
be the length of the longest one
we can kind of
see yeah we get these vectors cool
but um
let's plot this out so what we're doing
is we're looking at a scope we're
looking at all 20 speakers so across
this whole series there's 20 unique
speakers total
and we're looking at the duration
right so as we saw the longest podcast
about 6 300 seconds let's look at just
the 6000 seconds
and we get this visualization that's
pretty interesting it's like a con
concentration of speech
and we can see some patterns that make a
ton of sense here right we can see that
you know speakers zero through five are
pretty regularly talking you know in the
first
you know opening thousand seconds of the
podcast right
but as we get into like these longer
podcasts you can see that that drops off
because this is usually just resigned to
like like episode 12 for example which
is the longest one um we can also see
that like down here you know we have we
we record there being 20 unique speakers
but we can see that some of those
speakers really don't play much of a
role
speaking role and this might be because
they played like a video in the podcast
or played an audio clip in the podcast
or maybe they just had a guest on for a
couple of questions
we can take like a closer look at this
if we narrow the scope down to just 100
seconds
you can see
some segments here it's like wow speaker
one is typically speaking like across
all 20 podcasts like 35 percent of the
time he's talking in this like segment
here um
which is pretty interesting um we can
narrow down the scope of the speakers as
well if we only want just like look at
like four of them for example and you
kind of get this picture
so i think it's an interesting way to
visualize it and
kind of come back to this as we all wrap
it together to show how this can be
useful in a
real world case um
but i actually want to go back to the
slides
uh really briefly here
um
cool
all right so
just saw a ton of code and you've just
seen all the tools that we're using um i
now want to like push this idea or how
you can use these tools onto everybody
watching
um so now that we've looked at our tools
and we've seen some of the data that we
can extract with them uh i want to see
what you guys can come up with um
now our apis cost on like a per minute
basis uh but if you sign up for account
you get like 200 free minutes um a month
which is like great for testing the apis
but say you want to do your own podcast
project like i've done here
you're going to need more minutes
and that's why if you like navigate to
the link on screen
and i'll post it in chat for a second
um there's an option to fill out a form
and in this form you can talk about like
a cool idea that you want to use
and
it can include our api it can include a
bunch of like the transcription stuff uh
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
pick out like five of our favorite ideas
uh and we're either gonna do that like
live like at the end of this session if
we have enough time or i'll do it after
and we'll reach out via email
um but you pick out like
five of our favorite ideas and we're
going to credit you with an additional
300 minutes so you'll have a total of
500 minutes which is like a fair bit of
uh
of like computation time that's like
enough to like look at a series of
podcasts or something
um
and we'll
credit those minutes to you so you can
maybe go mess around and try to do your
own analysis
um
we're also going to check back in to the
form on november 8th
uh to credit an additional five ideas
with more minutes uh and we're doing
this just because like maybe you don't
have an idea right now but maybe you're
thinking about it later today and you go
actually that's a cool idea i wonder if
i can get some minutes to uh to try that
out um and we'll we'll credit those
minutes to you um or we'll credit it to
five today and five on november 8th so
if you want to win some minutes now go
fill out the form we'll pick our five
favorite ideas later today and another
five ideas next week feel free to submit
as many different ideas as you want
a cool kind of halloween thought starter
that might inspire you on a potential
project is performing analyze on like
some true crime podcasts to see if you
can detect like the most dramatic part
of the podcast
and this can kind of be done by like
looking at stuff like the loudness like
you know maybe it's a group of them and
they're reading scary stories and they
all go whoa at one point you know and
you can detect that as being a dramatic
moment or you can look at like when
people are talking and the relationships
between talkers or speakers
um there's a lot of different ways you
can you can look at solving these
problems you can get creative with it
um now let me go share this link into
the chat
sweet oh looks like you already
shared it so thank you uh and i'm gonna
switch back to my notebook a little uh
now so
cool we've looked at all of these tools
uh and as i mentioned before i was using
these tools in the context of better
understanding podcasts coming up with
some
ideas um so let's kind of recap on a few
of the things we looked at we saw the
views per episode cool we got a spike at
12 right
we saw the composition of podcasts and
it's interesting to note actually that
the quality or the number of speech
defects in these podcasts actually
improve as the podcast goes on
uh and this is like you can see this
kind of happens after like episode 12 it
like decreases down a little bit
uh and this is interesting to think
about right if we plot them out
on the same graph we can see the
percentage of silence which is an audio
defect and the number of downloads and
we can see after they have their huge
spike in popularity at like episode 12
the number of audio defects decreases
pretty dramatically right
and this raises like an interesting
question like is there a relationship
between episode 12 doing really well and
their audio quality improving you know
did they get some success and with that
success you know they hired an audio
engineer or
just because their podcast was seen by
more people
somebody just complained about it enough
and they're like all right we're gonna
fix it
um and it's an interesting thing to
think about in the context of the
podcast
now one of the ideas i kind of had was
all right well let's learn a little bit
more about episode 12.
so again we like tokenize out this stuff
we filter out all those stopping words
like what kind of words are we
mentioning in here well
it's pretty standard stuff it's kind of
similar to what we saw in number one
where you get three
um
you know you get other words
yeah various stuff
of different levels of interest and if
we look at the
speech
for episode 12 specifically so just
episode 12 and we plot it out
it's important to note actually that
this vector
this vector is just going to be
a bunch of zeros and ones monologues
this empty vector here is just going to
be
some zeros and ones and this is just
because we're not overlaying all the
podcasts in the series now uh now we're
just specifically looking at episode 12.
and we can see in the first 100 seconds
you know the host introduces maybe the
guests introduce
they kind of talk back a little bit back
and forth you can take out the scope a
little bit you can see wow it's really
like a back and forth conversation
so we have all this data what's
something interesting that we can do
with it and if we think about in the
context let's imagine this podcast has
just had a ton of success in episode 12
and a sponsor approaches them and they
go hey we want to put an ad in your
podcast is there a good way we can do
that algorithmically
and so the way i came up with in the
broader context of my podcast research
was to specifically look at when
certain kinds of organizations are named
in the podcast
now to do this we load in the display
transcript so we get all the punctuation
we tokenize it out
we use the pos tag to flag out things
like nouns and verbs
and understand like the composition of
the words that they're saying
we use this function any chunk which
then organizes all this stuff into a
hierarchy
and with that hierarchy we can actually
call out specific things such as
organization
that's worth noting here i'm using a
natural language toolkit spacey is a
pretty good alternative but i figure
we've looked at enough tools let's just
keep it simple
and we can flag out some of the
organizations that are mentioned in
episode 12. and we see things like okay
cool a lot of basketball teams um
like geico which is an american
insurance provider
uh and a bunch of stuff like that uh we
even see like yeti which are like
the cups
um
that's pretty interesting right so we
get a ton of these different uh
organizations here
so what if like a more natural way of
inserting ads into a podcast is rather
than just like put them at the start put
them at the end put them at the halfway
mark
we looked for particular points
where the host brought something up like
maybe he was talking about geico and he
was like oh yeah like got in a car
accident geico was great for my
insurance right
i believe it'd be a lot more compelling
for then an ad to kind of like pop out
for geico at a natural point after that
so use the transcription to flag out
this particular
section uh in this case i'll use the
target word the box i'm not a box fan
but we use we use the box and we'll look
at when they mention them right
so they have this sentence here
who should well the bucks should win
though right
uh and it starts you know about 57 uh
minutes in
now the interesting thing about this is
like
well we need to
take context into account because if
they're saying some like terrible things
about the box we don't want to insert a
bucks ad right after
so
what we can do is we can look at
the sentiment of the sentences around
when they bring up the box
so we can see we take three sentences
before
they mention that and then three
sentences after and they kind of have
different lengths of these sentences
and we can see that this negativity or
the negative sentiment captured is below
the average for the podcast and the
positive sentiment is above the average
which we calculated way back when we
were just looking at transcriptions
so this suggests that in this point they
are talking like a little bit more
favorably
about these podcasts
so what we can do now is i can actually
pull out the segment of audio here and
we can give it a listen and you can
decide for yourself whether you think um
it is a
good place to put an ad or a bad place
to put an ad
it's gonna navigate to 57
minutes here
cool
um now let me know
if the sun's lose why okay so the eagle
mercelio are you able to hear that audio
when i play it like that
yep we are able to hear the audio you
just played yeah great great thank you
chris paul you the guy right
so
who should the buck should win though
right
but the team's left i feel like the
bucks have the best case of like we
should you can talk yourself and i think
they have the best player left
yeah if kawhi were healthy it would be
different
so we can see in this segment here
they're they're talking pretty favorably
about it they're in fact saying that the
bucks should be the one to win uh win
the competition right
now uh
this is probably a pretty good place to
insert a bucks at you know they're
talking favorably about the bucks maybe
you have a viewer that doesn't have an
nba team they're on the fence they're
trying to decide which one they support
this guy says the bucks are going to win
and then you get an ad you know at a
natural point after that that says hey
you want to buy bucks tickets or you
want to buy box jersey or come check out
the bucks website you're gonna probably
be more likely to do that than if they
just inserted that kind of arbitrarily
into the podcast
um you know because if you trust the
host and you like what he's saying and
you think that he's right well then
getting an ad for that is such a more
compelling call to action than that ad
just waiting till the end for example
uh now the challenge here is inserting
this like naturally into the the
flow of the conversation right if you do
it just on the transcripts well you can
throw it right in after you know after a
period right after a full stop
but that kind of can interrupt the flow
of the conversation because it's a
podcast they're having this chat they're
jumping back and forth it's a bit
awkward if
a box ad just appears like midway
through a conversation interrupting at
the end of someone's sentence
but at the same time you don't want to
wait too long you want to be top of mind
for the viewer
so you want to insert it kind of a more
natural point
now if we look at our data that we got
from our speech analyze api
we can kind of see this point here
this right here is where the
10th speaker which is the guest the guy
that you heard talking is is speaking
about his stuff
now this is where he mentions the box
right and then this is like the
following like
how much i got the following 20 seconds
after that now there's a few different
points here but you can see the
conversation keeps jumping back i want
to call out specifically though this
section here where there's a gap between
the speakers
now if we have a closer look at this
we can actually see and this is just us
like checking who's speaking when or
checking when speech is happening
we can actually see a few points where
silence is occurring in the podcast and
again silence is an audio defect and
that's what's happening in this segment
here there's there's a silence section
where nobody is is saying anything now
this is a pretty good indicator that the
point has like finished or the
conversation is kind of taking a more
natural pause rather than just throwing
it in at the end of a sentence
so in this little pause section here
what we can do is we can kill two birds
with one stone we can fix the silence
section and insert an ad there since
because there's a silent section it's
probably a pretty good place for for an
advertisement
uh and if we look at this here we can
flag out a few silent sections that
occur this is 12 seconds after he says
the bucks are going to win
39 seconds and we see this nice segment
here of 47 seconds to 48 seconds which
is probably a pretty compelling place to
uh insert an app
cool
i'm going to switch back to the slides
now
and oh that was a lot of code and that
was a lot of me talking at you i just
wanted to give everybody just a quick
second to
take a deep breath i'm going to have a
drink of water and then we're going to
move on
a general reminder uh you can still
share your ideas and win api minutes i
really would look forward to seeing some
cool ideas on there and want to make
sure that we can get some resources to
those ideas so they can maybe
investigate this so
feel free even if you feel like the idea
is really simple or dumb
i think there's a lot of a lot of cool
stuff you can do out there
all right so meanwhile i'm going to read
some of the comments from our
participants
tom mentioned that it would be quite
interesting to run it on comedian doing
impressions impressions yeah
that would be
and they also mentioned about possible
overlapping tracks in the podcasts right
that was mentioned by ia
then tom also mentioned that it would be
curious to see how those packages are
tested
yeah well so again my i'm not actually
one of the engineers that builds these
packages so i can't give you a ton of
insight into that but um
if you uh reach out to me over slack and
you are really interested i can put you
in contact with uh some of the people
that do work on that stuff and they can
give you a bit more of an in-depth
explanation as to how how these kinds of
models are trained um
yeah all right i we're kind of running
out of time here so i'm gonna
keep going um
cool so
just to recap we looked at common words
where these words occurred we filtered
out stopping words
we looked at like sentiment
distributions throughout the podcast
to see maybe which episodes are kind of
more negative or which ones are more
positive based on the model that we're
using
we looked at doing some clustering to
see if we can find some natural
divisions between certain kinds of
podcasts as well as looking at the
relationship
that those podcasts might have
we also uh had a look at these metrics
that we used for that clustering kind of
individually to to show like kind of how
distinct some of these differences can
be
we looked at the composition by podcasts
so we can see like oh where are the
audio defects where
uh how much speech is in it how much
music is in it
um and we also had a look at like all of
the speakers as they're like you know
going through their their uh whole
podcast thing and we had to look at like
some patterns some macro level patterns
that you can identify when you're
looking at like 20 podcasts you can see
well there are kind of patterns to when
people talks talk and there's areas of
higher intensity um as well
um and then we had a look at you know a
specific use case in episode 12 where we
tried to uh find a more natural way to
insert ads we had a look at these
talkers and they're in a heated
discussion they're talking over each
other a little bit but we found a like a
nice segment where it might be more
relevant to insert an ad
um yeah that's kind of what we've
covered and now i want to take a second
to since we do have some time to have a
look at some of the ideas uh everybody
else has come up with
um so please if you haven't had a chance
go fill out that form i definitely think
uh i definitely think people have some
like cool ideas like don't don't be shy
to share them i i won't say anybody's
name um but we can kind of talk through
like a few of the cool ideas and maybe i
can point out some parts in the data
that that might be a little relevant
um cool so let's have a look at some of
these ideas
so here's here's a pretty uh relevant
idea especially with like the
transcription
stuff
is to convert a particular like host
or talker's notes into kind of like
cliff notes
almost or like a
summary of them in a way where you can
see like oh like what guests were saying
stuff and who were his key guests uh and
and which guests were you know
particularly relevant
um identify how often speakers interrupt
this is this is a funny one i'd love to
see that like
in like a classroom setting or something
like that where people
jump into calls
um
you know without their microphones muted
or whatever and it kind of interrupts
the flow of the conversation because
somebody's almost like interrupting the
virtual conference so i like that idea
that that'd be an interesting one
um we also do stuff like um
analyze particular podcasts
um and try to pull out specifically like
we have all those speakers which one is
the host and
is he the host because he's saying
things a certain way is he like talking
about himself a lot
uh is he taking the spotlight away from
the guests is he is he uh doing some
stuff like that um yeah
and so those are a few of the ideas uh
another one of the ideas i like this one
from griffin it is a podcast auto
segment highlighter
and
okay okay i've got it so it's like
i get this idea i like this idea this is
cool right it's the idea that if you
have a like a twitch stream or
presentation you know where these
streamers are like streaming games or
whatever there's obviously like segments
of their like three or four hour live
streams that are like
highlights right and if there was a way
that you could particularly like flag
out the highlights by looking at like
how there's talking and like loudness i
like that idea that's a that's a cool
one i can see how that's pretty related
as well to like the idea of trying to
determine the most intense part of a
podcast but that's kind of cool and i
can imagine that you build a tool that
like automatically clips out these like
segments of audio
so
that's pretty cool if anybody else has
other ideas like please uh submit them
in the form
come back to it we're looking to you
know give away uh some minutes uh so
that people can go and experiment with
this stuff and and do some of their own
cool uh projects
i also want to leave a quick second here
in case there are um any other questions
oh i see some right here
just one project idea not necessarily
feel free to go through and submit like
as many times as you want um
you know like if you've got a cool idea
or if you've got a bunch of ideas just
shoot them on i don't mind looking
through them um and we keep track of
your email and we use the email to
credit you and we can also reach out
and talk to you about your projects if
you you know if you
need help or have some interesting uh
questions and stuff like that
yeah i think one interesting question
comes by uh tom he's he's asking about
if the application is able to
apply it for different languages for
foreign language languages actually
yeah so um because the
api works on the signal specifically and
it doesn't like
convert it to a transcript and then run
it on the transcript uh it does in
theory work for a bunch of different
languages
in practice english
is kind of the most effective
one
but that's not to say that it doesn't
work on other languages you can test out
because it's working
it's not like it doesn't convert it into
like a human language it kind of does
like what we were looking at with the pi
audio
analysis package where it pulls out like
these signal based features
um and it has been tested on other
languages and it does work on other
languages but
as a blanket statement doesn't work on
all foreign languages it's hard for me
to say i i don't know that one for sure
any other
any other questions
well
let's see does anybody have any other
question we still have like five minutes
left
and please do not forget to go into the
dolby web app in order to propose your
ideas i think these projects are quite
interesting and would be applied in
several fields and post podcasts
yeah absolutely
that's a good question for
transcription
depending on which transcription you're
using this can be different uh in azure
it provides
a couple different versions
it provides like flat the words in order
which is the lexical that i kind of
looked at at the start for stuff like
common word mentions
uh and then for
uh and then like
it also provides examples where it
attempts to insert punctuation
uh in practice the punctuation it
inserts is very basic uh i don't think
i've ever seen it use um
a like semicolon or a comma it's mostly
just full stops
question marks exclamation marks
it's a good question how does it
recognize a question that that is a good
question i'm going to be honest i
actually have no idea how the
transcription does that part um that'd
be a good question for the people at
azure i think um but i guess as well it
probably works on the signals in a
similar way again to what we're looking
at pi audio stuff and maybe there's like
a particular
uh pattern in the sim in the signals
that allows you to denote like a like a
question or something like that in a
particular language i don't know
there's another question which says
how about punctuation which is inserted
versus punctuation is inserted
versus punctuation is inserted yeah i
see what tom's getting at there is it
like
punctuation is inserted or is it
punctuation is inserted
i again i'm not i'm not 100
sure but i think
sometimes even human beings have this
problem
right of like sometimes people can even
just say stuff and you're not sure
whether it's like an actual question or
whether they're just making a statement
like a rhetorical question
but that'd be an interesting question
for the people over at azure uh maybe a
bit of google investigation
um if you're if you're honestly if you
want to chat about it some more um
you know my
details are included here uh and this is
open to everybody if you want to reach
out to me via twitter um or my linkedin
is pretty easy to find braden riggs
and you want to chat about this stuff i
mean i'm continuing to work on these
projects
and it doesn't necessarily have to be
dolby related i'm kind of just uh doing
a lot of research in the space in
general uh so if you do want to have
like conversations about it
please reach out i love i love chatting
about it and of course i can't cover
everything in uh
in this whole workshop
yeah
and if we've got no more questions um
you know i i just want to say thank you
for everybody coming to this
presentation of course if you're
interested in learning more about our
apis please navigate over to our
documentation which is on screen right
now or if you want to share more ideas
absolutely feel free to do so
again we're going to try and credit out
a few people with some
some minutes so that they can maybe play
around and try out their idea of course
like you don't have to do it we just
give you the minutes and you can go go
try it out like there's no expectations
or anything like that it's totally your
project but if you do want some more
minutes to maybe go do your own um
investigation where we're happy to help
you out with that stuff
um and we'd also love to get your
feedback on this presentation
uh so please reach out to me via slack
or or twitter
um and thank you for
uh everybody watching i hope everybody
enjoys the rest of uh pycon
or pi data
thank you so much uh brayden i think
your talk was was quite interesting and
constructive several tools applied
the algorithm was fully explained and
also following several other example
codes so i think it became a really
great experience for everybody i also
want to thank tom
[Music]
el which
provided good feedback and somehow
enriched this conversation i think most
of our participants are congratulating
you
like olga she says great talk here again
is thanking a lot great material deliver
just to keep it up
good presentation by ignatia race we
also have a json who is clapping for
your presentation
well thank you everybody for the
feedback again these samples are uh
provided
if you want to just go tinker around
with it yourself i'll also work at
adding the
slides to the same um
github repo if you want to also have a
quicker or closer look at the slides i
should say here i'll re repost that
right there
and again another call to action if
anybody is just an audio data enthusiast
and wants to
go contribute on the awesome audio
that's just open to anybody doesn't have
to be related to any of the stuff that
we are doing
um just has to be related to you know
audio development and audio technology
in general so
i'll share this link as well please uh
yeah feel free to contribute and come
join the awesome community that we're
building around audio data all right
thank you very much everybody we have to
leave the room since other presentation
might be started thank you very much
everybody thank you so much again
brayden i hope we see you soon
again